let's face it there are a lot of us
and it's getting more than a little
crowded
right now there are over 7.7 billion
people on earth
and the united nations predicts we'll
have 8.6 billion people
sometime in 2030 and that's a problem
many scientists think earth can only
support
9 to 10 billion people we're running out
of room
but could there be a way to get more
land
to accommodate our ever increasing
population
enter the atoll made of donut-shaped
underwater mountains and islands formed
by underwater volcanoes could these
submerged rings of land be just the
thing we need
to create more living space what if
we could drain the world's largest atoll
would we be able to benefit from this or
would it make things way worse
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we drained the world's largest atoll
an atoll forms when an underwater
volcano
also known as a seamount erupts with the
lava from the volcano
hardening as it hits the water after
many eruptions
the sea mount groves until it rises
above the water
you've probably seen one of these before
we call them
islands the hardened lava under the
water then
becomes a home for many living organisms
especially corals
as the corals grow they form a fringing
reef around the island
over time the reef continues to grow
and the island begins to shrink as the
island shrinks
the reef remains and the corals begin to
grow
upwards then it becomes a coral rim
which means you've got a nice chunk of
land accompanied by
a warm shallow and salty lagoon
and atoll atolls are some of the most
beautiful habitats in the ocean
they're some of the most evolved coral
reef systems
in the world homes for thousands of
species of plants and sea creatures
the largest of them all is none other
than the great
chagas bank this atoll has a massive
area
of 12 642 square kilometers
could this be our new redevelopment
project
well if we were to drain this at all and
fill it with sand concrete or any other
solid material
we'd have some brand new land there
the development of these new areas would
begin immediately
with the economic boost coming soon
after
it would go something like this more
land
means more space for people more people
means more development more development
means more jobs
and more jobs mean more money
so sounds like a winner right well
not so much remember those coral reefs i
mentioned before
well we kind of need them and
when i say kind of i mean we absolutely
need coral reefs
but if we drain the water around them
the reefs die about eighty percent of
the oxygen you breathe
comes from the ocean not from land
we need healthy oceans to produce oxygen
healthy oceans need coral reefs do you
see what i'm getting at
and if you're still hung up on the lost
profits from not draining the atoll
get this coral reefs are essential
breeding
spawning and feeding grounds for more
than 4
000 species of fish those fish are a
major source of food for
over a billion people worldwide the
national marine fisheries service
estimates the annual commercial value
from the coral reefs
at over 100 million dollars
and that's not even getting into how
they act as coastal bodyguards
healthy coral reefs have rough surfaces
and
complex structures that scatter much of
the force of incoming waves
this means that these reefs act as
buffers for currents
waves and storms coastlines protected by
reefs
are a lot more stable so
it's best that we don't kill these
silent heroes of the sea
just because we can do something doesn't
mean we should
draining an atoll is certainly possible
but
draining the world's atolls would have
catastrophic effects worldwide so
let's rethink this what if instead of
draining water out of the atolls water
became
a new home for us what if we could find
that extra room we need by
building underwater cities
well that's a story for another
what if